(upbeat music)
- I have had one beer.
(laughing) I'm so buzzed!
- Time to get drunk!
- What are you making?
- 5% vodka, 95% orange juice.
- One, two, three.
(gasping and gagging)
- It's not gonna hurt,
it's not gonna sting,
it's not gonna taste like
(crying) burning alcohol, it's just fine!
- Turn up!
I'm gonna throw up.
- I don't wanna die alone!
Will you drive me home?
- It's only 8:30.
(girl whimpers)
- Buddy.
- Oh, a beer, I like these beers.
(liquid trickling)
- I can't believe I
finished this so quickly!
- Guys, I have to admit something.
I suck at drinking.
- (sigh of relief) Me too!
- I also suck at that! (laughs)
- I'm so bad at it!
- Ah, thank you!
- You guys, we should just pretend
to be drunk and dance like idiots.
- Yes!
- Uh, yes!
(music intensifies)
(singing) Oh, man, I'm
feeling so good tonight!